Meses después, ella bromeaba de que su esposo
la había amenazado con sacarla de la clase,
al enterarse de que su esposa ahora leía y escribía
y que podía ver los mensajes texto de su teléfono.
(Risas)
Esa traviesa Umm El-Saad.
Pero esto no es por qué Umm El-Saad se unió al programa.
Yo vi como ella anhelaba ganar control sobre sus simples rutinas diarias,
pequeños detalles que damos por sentado,
desde contar dinero en el supermercado a ayudar a los niños con sus tareas.
A pesar de su pobreza y mentalidad de su comunidad,
donde se menosprecia la educación de las mujeres,
Umm El-Saad, junto con sus compañeras de clases egipcias,
ansiaban aprender a leer y escribir.
En Túnez, conocí a Asma,
una de las cuatro mujeres activistas que entrevisté.
la estudiante de bioingeniería es muy activa en las redes sociales.
Respecto a su país, conocido por acunar lo que ha denominado Primavera Árabe,
ella dijo, "siempre he soñado en descubrir una nueva bacteria.
Ahora, después de la revolución, tenemos una nueva cada día."
Asma se refería al aumento del fundamentalismo religioso en la región,
lo cual es otro obstáculo particular para las mujeres.
De todas las mujeres que conocí, Fayza de Yemen fue la que más me afectó.
Fayza fue obligada a abandonar la escuela a los 8 años cuando se casó.
El matrimonio duró un año.
A los 14 se convirtió en la tercera esposa de un hombre de 60 años,
y a los 18 era madre divorciada de tres hijos.
A pesar de su pobreza,
a pesar de su estatus social de divorciada en una sociedad ultraconservadora,
y, a pesar de la oposición de sus padres de regresar a la escuela,
sabía que la única manera de asumir el control de su vida era mediante la educación.
Ahora ella tiene 26 años.
Ella recibió una donación de una ONG local
para financiar sus estudios de negocios en la universidad.
Su objetivo es encontrar un empleo, alquilar un lugar para vivir,
y traer a sus hijos de vuelta con ella.
Los estados árabes están pasando por cambios tremendos,
y las luchas a las que las mujeres se enfrentan son abrumadoras.
Al igual que las mujeres a las que fotografié,
tuve que superar muchas barreras para convertirme en la fotógrafa que soy hoy.
Muchas personas a lo largo del camino diciéndome qué y qué no podía hacer.
Umm El-Saad, Asma, Fayza y muchas otras mujeres en todo el mundo árabe,
demuestran que es posible superar las barreras mediante la educación.
Ellas saben que es el mejor medio para un mejor futuro.
Y aquí me gustaría terminar con una cita de Yasmine
una de las cuatro mujeres activistas que entrevisté en Túnez.
Yasmine escribió:
"Cuestiona tus convicciones.
sé quién quieres ser y no quién ellos quieren que seas.
No aceptes su esclavitud. Desde que tu madre dio a luz tú eres libre."
Gracias.
(Aplausos)